[Applause]
in today's interconnected world were
constantly bashed by conflicting
information on what we should and
shouldn't be eating but if there's one
thing that we can all agree should
definitely not be part of our diets hits
nuclear waste in the movies
ingesting radioactive materials like
uranium results in all sorts of crazy
hijinks like obtaining superpowers but
what would happen if you ate it in real
life how would it change your body and
how do we know that we're not eating it
already this is what if and here's what
would happen if you ate uranium uranium
is a naturally radioactive material that
was one of the main elements used to
make the nuclear bombs of World War two
but you don't have to be a mad scientist
to be exposed to it the Environmental
Protection Agency says that the average
person eats up to 1.1 micrograms of
uranium per day how is it getting into
our food and how much can we eat before
it starts to do damage I know what
you're thinking I wash and inspect every
piece of food I put into my body and
I've never noticed any glowing green
materials well it's not that simple for
one thing contrary to what pop culture
tells you uranium and most other
radioactive materials do not actually
glow and on top of that the uranium we
eat isn't being secretly sprinkled on
top of our food by some covert
organization so you can remove your
tinfoil hats for now instead the uranium
we eat is coming from within our food
and it's getting there naturally uranium
occurs naturally in soil rock and water
and it can be released into the air
through wind and water erosion and
volcanic eruptions in the air uranium
exists as dust that falls onto plants
and land especially during heavy
rainfalls once on land the uranium seeps
into the soil and sticks to plant roots
making root vegetables like potatoes
radishes and turnips its primary means
of getting into our diets but don't
worry the amount of uranium we ingest on
a daily basis is not nearly enough to do
any damage
luckily for us almost 99% of the uranium
that enters our body through food also
makes a quick exit through our feces and
seventy percent of the remaining uranium
that doesn't go through the backdoor
just leaves a bit later through
urination a tiny amount will stay within
your bones for a few months or even
years after eating it but won't have the
same toxic effects you'd experience if
you inhaled it
now just because we all survived
ingesting it every day doesn't mean we
should be eating big chunks of it and
starting to the uranium challenge online
eating large doses of uranium would be
very dangerous if you consume 25
milligrams of it you'd immediately start
to experience kidney damage and anywhere
past 50 milligrams could cause complete
kidney failure and even death if you did
survive those meals you still wouldn't
be in the clear because long-term
radiation exposure can lead to increased
chances of cancer and changes in brain
chemistry so yeah if someone collapse a
big chunk of uranium on your plate
you're probably best to pass and tell
them you've had your share for the day
and who knows maybe there are a whole
bunch of other strange materials
secretly entering our bodies on a daily
basis but that's a topic for another
what-if
[Music]